so if you don't go on tick-tock or you
like to pretend you're too cool for
tick-tock there is a young lady by the
name of Charlie D'Amelio she has
literally [ __ ] exploded on this
[ __ ] half and so how many followers
does you have 5 million 5 million
yeah and how long I don't know I'm like
scrolling down to like see how far back
she posted it's my understanding that
she has just been like just a regular
fifteen-year-old kid on this app and
then a bunch of creepos and dude started
like duetting her videos and like some
of them not knowing that she was [ __ ]
15 okay
which you know maybe on this is just age
here when I look at her I see a [ __ ]
child yeah it's like her mannerisms and
everything like she has all the makings
of a [ __ ] yeah I mean and that like
whatever video you showed me or
something that popped up when we were
like searching her it was like clearly
in a [ __ ] middle school yeah yeah or
high school or whatever I mean like it's
if they're made
tic TOCs in your bedroom is like you are
definitely in high school yeah I don't I
mean yeah yeah 100% no but tic TOCs in
English class yeah even even more so
yeah definitely probably a kid but
either way so weird is dead-on tick tock
yeah so keep going it goes out to her
dad Charlie d'emilia was dead um so her
dad has a tick tock now yeah and he you
know he gets in on all the good trends
you know like no not November he's got
you got it you got a heater on that one
no way yeah no way yeah is there music
in it can you pull it up we'll pull it
up okay I wanna start there
I'm gonna start with the known on
November 1 I mean I feel like that's a
pretty good place to start it gives a
little perspective on who this man might
be a November babies no you know what
I'm gonna be part of this
down with the cause and so I'm like
alright I mean but posit can you pause
it
but [ __ ] is he going with this you'll
see this is exactly what an open mic
feels like this is 2,000 percent this is
the most open mic experience you can
have on the Internet this feeling you
all have of like where the [ __ ] is the
punt this isn't open why is the premise
okay alright I also gotta say this is
the longest tick-tock if I've already
listened to you I mean I don't know it's
already been like what 10 seconds only
but still it feels like the longest dick
dawg
no one's ever built up of [ __ ] a joke
joke like this on tick-tock
yeah yeah ready okay get ready so you
did all that I said all that just to
pull out a bag of almonds and go I'm out
I can't do it I'm out of no nut November
he kind of [ __ ] up the whole thing
bite he killed his own action by saying
that that digesters yes yeah he knew
where it was going
yeah I knew where it was going damn
that's a tag brah yeah she said that
afterward after yeah yeah mmm damn so
that's not the weird part you know
that's a that's a that's an innocent dad
thing to do right yeah by the way a
little that's a that's a [ __ ] that's
a bad dad joke yeah I think dad jokes
usually pretty good that's a bad one
yeah well also um I love how oh he talks
he's the rock what's up tick-tock what's
up brother how's the big that's starting
your tic TOCs with what's up tick-tock
is [ __ ] yeah alpha yeah yeah that's
pretty sad um what's up what's up take
saga alright so here we go this is this
is up man I'm in Cabo dude oh actually
now I can't this is a this is my okay so
this is why he's getting nominated ready
what's up tick-tock this is going out to
all the boys who called my house
text me emailed me my name is mark de
Mille Oh I am Charlie D'Amelio and
Dixie's Emilio's father you're welcome
what's up tick-tock oh my god
oh [ __ ] didn't I don't know this man
maybe I should give him a chance to
explain himself but I don't know how
much explaining you can do for that
statement cuz as [ __ ] weird
damn [ __ ] weird weird all youse kids
out there who was cold in my house
commenting on my videos
no I'm Charlie and dicks he's dead and
we just want to say you're welcome for
my out [ __ ] kids also I'm gay also
I'm [ __ ] gay yeah that's it as
strangers ever had yeah that's bad
mm-hmm mm-hmm you're welcome for my hot
daughter your book about [ __ ] kids
that came from my dick i tweeted that
right from my balls i tweeted that video
and liked that caption and a bunch of
people were like didn't know I was
kidding okay people like random people
started playing to it being like ill
that's gross only all right never mind
yeah damn that's rough dude yeah so you
you rough mark you get the cleaver yeah
you get the cleaver for what was it
weirdest yeah yeah oh wait he's like cut
damn it through this just I would just
bite my tongue here but they're here
talking with Gary Vee who Mark Charlie
and Gary no way just having a nice
little way play it play it I want to
hear it you overvalue somebody
complimenting you that you're cool dad
and you have Easy's on then you're gonna
over value the hate to like I'm like
literally my comments are respect I love
it and they look cool but like literally
my comments are literally like you're a
snake oil salesman con artist and the
next one's your Jesus like literally
sure for sure dude like first
no no the interest and the more she can
practice it now and the more you
actually believe it and the more that's
the conversation what is like the most
not subtle humble yeah I know my comment
section is crazy some people they think
you know I'm most diabolical person on
earth and other people think I can turn
water to wine you see you know but you
know me I just walked right down the
middle yeah I don't pay attention either
yeah the others say you're you know a
super villain super successful is still
you know but like the evil and or you're
literally Jesus himself
you